شتاء اوكرانيا البارد انقضى ولم تقم كييف
بشن هجوم مضاد على القوات الروسيه لياتي
الحديث عن هجوم الربيع الذي سيبدا في
التاسع من مايو الجاري بحسب ضابط في قوات
لوغانس الانفصاليه المواليه للروس
رمزيه الهجوم المتوقع في هذا التاريخ تاتي
لكونه يوما مقدسا حسب تعبير الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين فهو يوم النصر على النازيه
وقد تستغله اوكرانيا للانقضاض على القوات
الروسيه شرق وجنوب اوكرانيا ومنذ اشهر
تكثف اوكرانيا استعداداتها لشن الهجوم
بالاستعانه بالاسلحه الغربيه المقدمه لها
خاصه الصواريخ والدبابات المتطوره التي من
المتوقع ان تزج بها اوكرانيا في الهجوم
المضاد
بالطبع ننتظر الهجوم عندها ستنتهي الحرب
على الارجح وسنفعل كل المتاح للوصول الى
حدود الف وتسعمائه وتسعين هذه الفرصه
الوحيده لاستعاده اراضينا والانتصار لذلك
نحن ننتظر على الجانب الاخر من الجبهه سبق
لقائد مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه
ان حذر من ان الهجوم المضاده الاوكراني قد
يؤدي لماساه بالنسبه لروسيا وابدم تعاضه
من الذخيره لدى مقاتلي محملا قياده الجيش
الروسي مسؤوليه ذلك
بدوره اعتبر وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويغو ان موسكو اتخذت اجراءات لتسريع
انتاج الاسلحه وزياده مخزوناتها من
الدخائر رغم ان الجيش لديه كل الاسلحه
التي يحتاجها في ساحه القتال لهذا العام
نتيجه لذلك ارتفع عدد الانواع الرئيسيه من
الاسلحه المشترى بثلاث مرات مقارنه بالعام
الماضي وبالنسبه للاسلحه المطلوبه بشكل
خاص فقد ارتفع الطلب عليها سبعه اضعاف هذا
العام قدمنا بالفعل ذخيره كافيه لضرب
العدو بشكل فعال
حسب مراقبين غربيين يواجه الجيش الروسي
تحديات عده في صد اي هجوم مضاد مع معاناته
من نقص الاسلحه المتطوره في مواجهه
الاسلحه التي بحوزه اوكرانيا ما دفع روسيا
لتبني نهج جديد قائما على استهداف قواعد
تجميع قوات الاحتياط الاوكرانيه في مسعا
لمنع وصول القوات الاوكرانيه الجديده الى
الخطوط الاماميه للقتال حسن غوليد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قنات على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات